SIMONE PETTIGREW: So autonomous vehicles feel new to most of us
as if we haven't heard much about them, but they've actually
been in progress for quite some time.
So the technological aspects of the development of the vehicles
have been tinkering away in the background for decades.
And if you think about the way that your vehicle works today
compared to what your parents might have experienced,
even the fact that they probably drive a manual and you
drive an automatic vehicle now.
So we've been seeing progressive improvements even down to your airbags
pop up automatically now if you have an accident.
But we have cruise control.
We've got little devices in the car that center us in the lane
if we want to use those kinds of devices.
Some cars are capable of self-parking, others flash and indicate to us
when we're getting too close to other objects.
So incrementally we've been increasing the amount of autonomous content
within a vehicle.
It's just a matter of time until we take that extra leap and the vehicles
become fully autonomous, which means that we won't need a steering wheel,
we won't need brakes or accelerators.
The vehicles will do all the driving for us.
They will be GPS based.
So we just tell them either verbally or program it in where we want to go
and the vehicle will be capable of taking us there.
So that's kind of like the end goal.
And because the vehicle will be talking to lots of other vehicles
it can assess the extent to which there are blockages in traffic
and pick different routes depending on the fastest possible available route
available at that point in time, depending
on how other many road users there are all trying to get to the same place.
So it really will be interesting times once
we move to the other end, the full end of the autonomous spectrum.
At the moment we have the capability for vehicles to be autonomous,
but there are kind of constraining factors
that are preventing that from happening right now.
And one of the major ones is the fact that we've got hundreds of road rules
all of which specify the driver.
So until those road rules can be changed we're still going to be in a situation
where we're not allowed to drive autonomous
vehicles in full autonomous mode.
However, within the next three or four years
we're looking at sort of certain precincts
probably being able to do that on Curtin campus, for instance,
we have our autonomous bus.
And that's allowed to be in autonomous mode because of the fact
that it's largely on private property.
So we'll kind of see individual areas, geographical areas introducing
autonomous vehicles first.
PAUL NICHOLLS: Hi.
I'm Paul Nicholls.
I'm the Director of Strategic Projects Research and Development
here at Curtin University, Perth, Western Australia.
This is Kip, our AV bus that we've had operating for about three months now
on the Curtin University campus.
The bus is called Kip after the Curtin University namesake.
So John Curtin.
Kip was the name of one of his dogs.
Curtin's purchased an AV bus because we think
it's a great way for us to trial these sorts of disruptive technologies.
The same as mobile phones have disrupted the way we operate.
And the internet has created all of these opportunities
to do things differently.
An AV bus can really disrupt the way that we operate in a community.
SIMONE PETTIGREW: In terms of when we might
look at having loads of different autonomous vehicles on the roads,
they say by about 2040 we may have around 3/4
of vehicles in fully autonomous mode.
So I think we can see quite rapid adoption of autonomous vehicles
coming up in the future.
But this is also an evidence based proposition
if you like because if you think back to the early 1900s
when the motorcar was first introduced, we've
got the situation where in New York City, for instance, in the year 1900
you had the Main Street with one car and all the rest being horse and carts.
13 years later, we've got the situation where
there's one horse and cart surrounded by motor vehicles.
So even back then in the space of 13 years
there was complete saturation of a new disruptive transport technology.
So if we extrapolate that out now to the 2000s,
and we're even more receptive to new technology
it's going to be more affordable relatively than it was back then.
I think we're looking at really fast adoption rates.
The future with autonomous vehicles will look
very different to the way it does now.
So in the interim period we'll probably still have things like traffic lights,
but the flows should be much better.
Ultimately, however, we're looking at a situation
where there are no traffic lights and those vehicles down to the millimeter
can be pinpointed.
They'll be each talking to more than 30 satellites,
as well as communicating with each other.
So they are perfectly well programmed to be able to mix in with each other
again down to the millimeter.
So you're looking at a situation of intersections
without traffic lights and traffic just merging.
So you'd have traffic coming from different directions
just blending it and keeping on going.
And I know that's a difficult concept to get your head around,
but longer term the computers are very well set up to be able to do that.
So for instance, traffic control at the moment for airplanes already does that.
We have the airplanes in the sky on automatic pilot for much of the flight
and we have computers determining when and where they're
going to pass other flights and when and where they are going to land.
So we do put our faith in these machines in some areas.
It's just going to be a matter of transferring that to motor vehicles
and getting used to that new system.
The logistics around that, of course, are
interesting because we're looking at a situation
where all the frequencies have to be the same.
So all the vehicles have to be talking to each other on the same frequency.
If only one vehicle has its GPS out by a few millimeters
it could create absolute havoc.
So we really need to have the system set up well enough so that they're
talking to each other with perfect compatibility,
that all of those vehicles are registering their location in exactly
the same way, and are able to communicate that to each other
immediately.
We'll have lots of spinoff benefits from that as well.
So the vehicles, as well as having their own senses
that can tell them what's in the immediate environment.
They can tap into what other vehicles are sensing.
So if there are potholes, if there are road signs missing,
if there are road works, the vehicles can immediately
communicate that to the network rather than each individual vehicle
having to learn each time it passes by that particular scene.
We can have huge savings in terms of trip times.
So we're very much looking at a blended system in order for it
to be as efficient as possible.
It would be quite inefficient if every individual wanted
to own their own autonomous vehicle, we would just end up with a whole bunch
more vehicles on the road.
So for instance, your vehicle would drive you
into the city in the morning to go to work.
It would turn around and drive itself home again, or take itself
somewhere else to recharge.
It would then come and collect you in the evening and take you home.
So rather than that vehicle just being on the road while you're in it,
it's now also on the road for quite a while you're not in it.
So multiply that out by the number of people in the population
and there's the potential for increases in congestion instead of decreases.
So we're very keen for public policy makers our governments to be proactive
in this space to make sure that we encourage
the rollout of autonomous vehicles in such a way
that we do prioritize public transport.
So we've got really good efficient public transport that
runs autonomously, as well as those backup last mile, first mile
services that can help people so that they
don't have to actually own a vehicle, but they can still
get really good transport to and from.
And then to have their own individual autonomous vehicle as the backup,
as the last thing that you would consider.
PAUL NICHOLLS: In the future, Curtin University
hopes to have a range of autonomous vehicles operating across the campus.
It'll help improve the experience of our students and the guests to the campus,
but also improve their safety.
Over time we expect that the level of autonomy of these vehicles
will actually improve to the point where we can take our technicians out
of the system and where we can go fully autonomous on the campus.
The vehicles we hope will be able to identify
where students are on the campus that need to be moved and actually
optimize the movement of those students across the campus.